-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're about
to play a game of "Catchphrase,"
but Tariq and I need partners.
Tariq, we found
a great one for you.
He is the voice of Superman
in the new movie,
"DC: League of Super-Pets,"
which is in theaters
this Friday.
Give it up for John Krasinski!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
Oh!
-How are you?
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Don't vote on those.
They're voting.
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
My partner is a Grammy-nominated
singer/songwriter
whose new album, "Surrender,"
is out on Friday.
Please welcome Maggie Rogers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Tariq, Maggie.
-So happy to see you.
-Thank you, thank you.
-John, Maggie.
Guys, here's how the game works.
I'm gonna start the round
by pressing start
on this buzzer right here.
John, you'll draw a clue
from the top of the pile.
You have to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible,
then hand the buzzer
to the person on your right.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
We're gonna play three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
I'm here.
-All right.
-Where are you?
You'll be across from me, right?
When you're ready,
I'm gonna press start,
and you're gonna draw the first
clue and go for this.
All right?
-Let's do it.
-All right, here we go.
-Okay.
-Come on, bud, we got this.
-All right, I'm ready.
-Let's connect.
-I'm ready.
I'm ready.
-Yes. Tap in. Yes.
-Go.
-Oh, okay.
-Um...
A fish that's very angry.
Has angry teeth.
-Shark.
-But they're little
and a lot of them.
-Oh, piranha.
-That's right.
-Wow! Very calm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Thank you.
-He's an ogre with green ears.
-Shrek.
-Yep.
-Wow.
-Oh, that's cheating.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's what pickles are
before they're pickled.
-Cucumbers.
-Damn
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When you're really angry
in a car at other people.
-Road rage.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's up?
-It's not -- It's --
you don't have this
on your yard,
you have it in your...
-In your house.
On your porch.
-It's when I'm selling things.
[ Cymbals crash ]
-Oh, a yard sale.
A sale.
Yard sale.
-In -- But in the --
-Garage sale.
-That's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a game, and you have to --
you're talking and you're giving
instructions, and it's a guy.
-Charades.
-Who's telling you instru--
[ Buzzer ]
-Simon Says.
[ Sad tuba ]
-No, no.
No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Can't believe you didn't
get "garage sale"
from "selling stuff
out of your garage."
-But I still got it, though.
I like how you said,
"Simon Says"
and still lost the round.
-That was a good hint.
That was a good hint.
Yeah, I was,
"Hm, sounds like 'garage sale.'"
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, 'Garage sale?'"
"Yes!
How'd you guess that?"
-That was a purposeful stall.
-Yes, yes.
-That was a great, great,
great hint.
-It's like at the end
of Hot Potato where you're like,
"Got him."
-It's part of our technique.
-You know what happened, though?
You started off so calm.
-Thank you.
-And then we all --
no, we all were calm.
And then we were really good.
And then -- [ Laughs ]
-And then I ruined it?
-No, yeah, kind of.
-Are we gonna edit
that part out?
-No, we're gonna leave that in.
-We're still calm.
-That was real.
It shows that you're human.
-Cool as a pickle
before it's pickled.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Come on, let's do it.
-That was a clue earlier.
[ Beeping ]
-Uh...
Okay, these are, you know,
chocolate, graham cracker,
marshmallow thingies.
-Oh, boy. S'mores?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-I'm in a pool.
-Oh, boy.
-Oh, I see.
[ Laughter ]
-We've all heard this story.
-Great.
-Playing a game
where I yell and you respond.
-Oh, um.
Uh...
-Yeah.
-Ralph Lauren makes a line of
clothing that sounds like this.
-Marco Polo.
-That's correct.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is a type of cookie.
-Graham cracker.
-But it's also
based on candy bar.
-Uh, uh, Rocky Road --
What is that thing?
-Yes.
It satisfies you.
The candy bar satisfies you.
-Oh, dang, a Snickers --
Snickerdoodle!
-Yes! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a dance that you do.
-Macarena!
-Okay. Um, um, um...
It's a TV show --
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Laughs ]
-We still got it.
We still got it.
-I have a question.
-What?
-Is it cheating
if she did the macarena?
-No!
-I didn't say anything.
-She didn't say anything.
-She was...
-No.
-We'll let her live.
-That was good.
But I did --
I will say, Tariq,
that was a good hint.
It's a TV show.
-Get out of here!
[ Laughter ]
-Should've got that one.
You should've got that one.
All right.
-Okay.
-Let's do one more.
[ Laughter ]
-We're doing great.
Don't listen to this.
-All right.
Come on, Jimmy, let's go.
-It is a, you know,
a plate that, you know --
another word for a spaceship.
-Rocket.
-No, a plate.
Like a plate.
-Oh, a UFO.
-No, like a plate.
Like, what do they call it?
[ Laughter ]
An aerial plate.
Aerial plate.
-Am I -- Am I an idiot?
-It's a plate-shaped thing
that aliens are on.
God!
-UFO, UFO.
[ Laughter ]
-No, John!
Old school!
What do they call it?
Old school.
Back in the day.
-Still a UFO.
-No, you see a UFO,
he lands in a what?
"Dude, I saw an aerial plate."
[ Laughter ]
-I got nothing.
-How you doing?
Everything good.
-It's dinnerware in the sky.
Dinnerware in the sky!
-Flying saucer.
-Flying saucer!
-God, yes!
[ Buzzer ]
Geez Louise!
-The winners -- me and
Maggie Rogers, right there!
Come on.
[ Ding! ]
-I am so sorry.
-Dude, you're good.
You were good, bud.
-I am so sorry.
-My thanks to John Krasinski --
You're about
to have a heart attack.
Maggie Rogers, Tariq Trotter!
We're talking to John
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!